[Music]
amazing that was a first look at Marvel
contest of Champions gameplay with a
very special member of the Fantastic
Four the first time anyone is given play
that on a live stream so exciting hey
everyone I'm ready okay agent m and I'm
Lorraine Cink Hey
and we are very excited to kick off our
Fantastic Four world's greatest week
event yeah we're gonna start gaming very
soon but first I've got to tell you this
is gonna be a really amazing week we're
celebrating the history and legacy of
Marvel's first family plus releasing
some very exciting things to come every
day between now and January 16th and to
get it all started we're here with you
live for the next two hours to give you
an all-encompassing first look at how
the Fantastic Four will be joining some
of your favorite Marvel games we have
characters who have never been playable
before the introduction of one of the
most No the most important Marvel super
villain and so much more and we're gonna
have so much fun here and we want you
guys to join us send us your questions
and comments using the hashtag fantastic
four week on Twitter and in the comment
section of facebook and youtube if you
want us to try out a character or to
give some pro tips or to try a totally
hard raid we're here and we're gonna try
it out for you
yeah alright so everyone here at marvel
headquarters totally geeking out to play
our first game there's an actual line of
Marvel Lights forming off-camera and
they're right to be excited because you
know we're playing for the first time
anywhere live the thing in Marvel
contest of Champions and we're not just
playing the thing oh no no no we're
gonna deep dive into the game character
which players face off in competitions
we're going to teach you some important
tips to help you win and talk about all
the things important history as Marvel's
first family with editor-in-chief CB
Cebulski
I know that guy but before all that
let's see the thing in action please cue
it up
I want to play this again but I I feel
like Lorraine
we've made our friends here at HQ wait
long enough to take their shot joining
us now is Marvel games own Tim Hernandez
who leads all mobile game work we do
here at Marvel and our own Earth's
Mightiest show co-hosts Langston Belton
who is just seeing the thing playable
for the first time thanks for joining
having a good time rationing time he's
like he's done okay
so you haven't played the thing yet
Langston no we're gonna have you play a
game and while we chat maybe once he's a
few rounds in we'll have you guys
face-off see how that goes you never
know
while he's doing that make sure to let
us know what you want the thing to do
who you want to see him go up against
using the hashtag fantastic for week
that's very important we want to hear
from you guys Larry is going to be
taking them on Twitter box but Langston
is getting ready in there this is this
is exciting this is anybody gets to see
the thing in action looks so good
he looks fantastic I know and first off
I do want to call out the thing is
wearing pants he is wearing boots
oh it's my lovely spandex yeah we
splurge for him let's my pants and those
boots to the nice sweet boots look at
those and that belt that belt is that
champions fantastic championship belt I
love it so we're gonna be getting some
questions here don't forget to hashtag
fantastic for week if you have any
questions there are so many cool things
that the thing does first and foremost
as a character what's his special skill
he's got amazing special abilities so
he's got three Langston is queuing up a
couple of them his first one this of
stone weight right to 3d Street meatball
now it's a Eng Street folder buried
was incredible torque Neverland so saw
and now that is quadrant I'm special
that is its clobberin time you went
straight to the business but you know
what that's fine I was I think they're
double was overwhelmed by the fact that
he's a fighting his friend who's made of
rocks oh now I'm dizzy
okay here we go this so now I have one
special so this is this is this of stone
oh very good look at that we're gonna be
playing a bunch and really like we like
to heckle each other we like to play
around and give each other a little
grief now if you guys who are watching
you know use that hashtag fantastic for
week and you can let us know how
Langston's doing be gentle with him you
might be gentle with all of us be kind
but you can those thing wins he brushes
his shoulder of like and now big deal
yeah okay so Langston you had a few
moments with the game we want to do
around what was your first impression of
playing with the thing it's so much fun
the thing it's a lot of fun to throw out
Nancy Street beat downs it's a he's the
the animation styles because it's these
big haymakers and stuff like that I also
love like the the blocking all the it's
just so much fun yeah it's it's it's
good play the thing please I mean the
team at command spent so much time it's
it's a true passion for them to get
these characters right and they've been
asking to do the thing for a while we
just try to find the right time just to
fit it into the roster and you know
obviously they blew it away yeah so we
saw Langston's first round and learning
a little bit about getting used to the
character and stuff like that but a game
like this it's you know - all of that
timing it's all about the combos it's
all about making sure you're blocking
and you're doing everything the right
way what what should we know about the
combos and the strategy to really make
your character work timing is especially
important for the thing he's got an
ability that's based a thing called on a
thing called rock stacks so the more you
block and the more you perfect block as
an opponent is hitting you you're gonna
start accumulating those rocks tax and
we'll go into a little bit more in
detail but he's a tank so he can take a
lot of damage so don't feel bad as
you're blocking those attacks he's in it
for the long game so you want to make
sure that you're you're putting a
defensive stance from the beginning but
building up and accumulating in so at
the very end you really
roll em up in a burrito and get
unleashed at its clobbering time special
yeah so for fans who have never seen
Marvel contest of Champions before
there's a lot of stuff happening
underthings health fun or what's all
that so on the far left is the rock
StatCounter
oh no huh yeah oh no Allred winkin if
you got away it's okay we saw plenty of
house so that that on the far left you
see that that gray circle that's the
rock stack so you want to get above 15
rock stacks and then once you have that
unleash your spell there it is there you
go oh yeah this might my new favorite
thing to watch all it's just great and
look what's going on all right
and your knock come out no is this first
time I know right I think that you guys
should actually face off okay it is time
to see how it goes the viewers at home
Tim works on these games he's a little
bit of a ringer a hard bar to clear and
while you're actually setting that up I
do want to ask you we know the the
character event for thing is based on a
classic comic title which is really yes
this man this monster classic Lee Kirby
storyline there's some there definitely
it's an homage to that but there's also
some of the plot points and story
elements that though the story's
original definitely touches on that so
if you're a fan of that series and of
course I encourage you guys to go check
it out
yeah there's some some great moments
some special moments yeah I'm very
excited for it okay thanks to move your
butt all right I'm trying okay okay I'll
heal doc I'm all done I got I gotta put
you back in Oh got a plug in here we go
gentle touch gentle touch magic all
healed up
I think might think they're gonna be
gentle with that flipping cord adjust
that cord okay we're gonna hit we had
fired the same show you go right this is
you know Langston has rigged this entire
that Tim bring me in and
he'll I got here nice and early and made
sure that it it did totally there we go
wait all right you know what you know
yep you go first
let's yeah let's uh I'll look at a
countdown and see how fast you can get
it done okay so how about go in yeah
yeah okay here we go
I wanted it to start the timer on go yep
go great start great it likes it think
you're gonna go right in
oh wow let's go oh god he's gonna okay I
lose this head start
oh god hawkeye's already doing some
damage all right clay come on come on
you got it we got a head start
Ben you've already got eleven raw specs
so oh you oh wow
also can I say kudos on the term rock
stacks it's fun to say I'm gonna start
it's just like a nice cereal that's the
beauty of Marvel games working with our
Marvel games partners everything feels
so natural so real and so authentic yeah
that's the key to this game is this the
the fluid gameplay it's built for mobile
from the ground up so it's a it's a
fighting game but it's very simple to
control and it's the action just really
did it well come on quick quick I'm
looking over and seeing like him getting
closer oh thank you for that assess god
this has been a little toss likes and
his finished thanks but he also had an
unfair haven't I like the unfair but
we're gonna do this proper yeah good job
Tim you had a good warm-up you needed a
little normal
clearly doesn't count there's both of
you let's start this our you know I'll
raise you let's take on Luke Cage we
need a real go let's do yeah let let's
take on Luke Cage and let's uh make sure
you heal your character prior yes Jim
can you talk us through how you heal
your character yeah absolutely so you're
gonna go in once you pick your opponent
there's a little story there we are I
okay I see it so as you see things bars
halfway he only has close to 8,000 at
12,000 so we're gonna press the heel
button down the lower left there and
let's go let's go let's go big all right
that easy delicious and now I'm maxed
out again
you good yeah I'm saying licious
delicious mango potion can we get some
mango potion I'm ready I'm ready to go
all right what on three one two three
that was where it was cutting the red
wire that's pretty good but the two
titans face off and the same instinct
all it's in the middle of the night too
so even strange to sleep right now
wondering Doctor Strange is walking down
just turns around back out of this man
in a loop must've gotten an argument
playing cards again oh okay here we go
so I some attacks don't think like don't
block so is there like yeah when you do
that Rock stack you want to get it to
about 15 and when you do that the
special attacks are unblockable so
interesting that's what I was saying the
long game is really important to get
those alive that's next
oh you're so with that oh oh and then
when you do your special those rocks
that turn into fury and so fury is gonna
add more damage to those attacks as you
quickly you see what happened is like
Stan was distracting Tim I mean all
conversation and give me them tips and
Tim is behind I know well Tim was just
like kind of holding them off doing
whatever well Langston was straight up
here we go
sweet see I I may have won but he got to
pull up towards a burrito so I like it
slow and steady approach I feel like a
failure
we've got time you guys are having a
great time you're doing really well
let's do best two out of three okay
let's just feels right yeah one more
match the heat comes to where we go so
who's next
alright so we have to go so we're gonna
take that that portal ooh so which path
do you want to go to I pick the last one
you pick this one I mean we've already
seen you guys play a couple of
characters how many characters are
playable in this game so there's over
140 characters oh and we launched two to
three a month so it's a constant
constant steady stream of Marvel
goodness okay we got vulture we have
Corvis core versus the business I don't
know oh you know what let's take it one
alright I believe in
guys whoever believes in you all right
so that was hopefully a right yeah so
port clearly remember that hashtag is
fantastic your week yeah don't forget to
heal yourself oh please he's because he
has a very large okay yeah it's it's a
very there's so much power in this game
it's overwhelming modern technology one
of those all right let's see how it goes
there's like the magic I know it's the
right combo you may have Lifeson may
have finally enacted his master plan
yeah you had you had a good a good way
of doing it before all right all right
okay well we're just gonna it was do we
hurry back hold it alright okay yeah
okay we'll get into the business I think
so yeah we're gonna we're just gonna say
that you guys are both very talented and
that is enough good enough yes we're
gonna have to send you back in line
bring in a new player I think I see mr.
Josh Saleh waiting in the wings back
there oh yeah oh and while we do that I
want to make sure to thank everybody
from watching our livestream to have us
read your comments here be sure to
interact with us on social using the
hashtag fantastic for week on Twitter or
in the comments section on the
livestream or wherever you're watching
you already have been sending us some
great stuff so let me take a couple of
little comments here we have I cannot
wait to clobber everyone in contest of
Champions with a thing agreed we also
have a question who is your favorite
Fantastic Four week member mine is thing
or she-hulk if she replayed if
replacements are allowed oh I like that
I like that
getting into the cannon Oh Sharon
Ventura is really cool too yes sure
dozens of members
the Fantastic Four over the years I mean
yeah it's it's been really fun actually
to see who swaps in from the Marvel
Universe so all about it yeah alright
we're done with social for now keep
sending them in but look who's joined us
it's Marvel gaming correspondent Josh
Soleil what's up guys thanks for having
me oh my gosh thanks for jumping in Josh
gotta ask what do you think of seeing
the thing so far oh my god he is
unstoppable
he's unbreakable he's a rock god he's a
tank is true you take you feel every
punch you can take a punch and you can
dish out three more just even like times
10 damage Josh I heard from a little
birdie that you actually got to play
this game before you got in line you've
been you know working your way through
this so why don't you call up an
opponent run us through what you most
like about the thing yeah absolutely
so what Tim was talking about earlier
was rocks tanks now rock stacks are huge
in order to make the thing strongest he
can be you want to build up those rocks
tax once you hit 15 your specials are
unblockable you cannot stop him ah the
bull which is insane on top of that he
gains a sus a special one 61% damage on
top which every single rock stack one
rock sack 61% damage on top so good just
that alone and all the abilities on top
of that bleed is the only thing that can
really hurt him because that takes off
Rock stack looks like you're going up
against a guy who might be able to make
you bleed yeah gonna heal I'm not gonna
heal yeah so so domino blade be gone egg
on Black Widow is gonna be deadly yes
absolutely and Black Widow especially
because she isn't make people believe
but she has that offensive ability
accuracy so she's gonna reduce the
things timing in Australia to get that
rock stack go I know that's the thing
about this game that it's so easy to
forget is they just as much as it's fun
to play a character you might have to
then fight that character and another go
around you know their weaknesses yeah
that's a great point
well isn't saying with a hundred reset
140 characters there's so many different
synergies and bonuses and classes and
it's just
so insane how much they put on just it's
so much that gosh you should have healed
I'm just saying I should have healed
well you know that's how shocking I
thought it was definitely yeah that's a
Hooper's clothes all that stage how many
hours have you played of Marvel contests
oh man when it first came out I can't
even count how many hours that put into
this game and it's crazy how many hours
I put into this I'm still not even in
the expert you know you've seen people
play this game they know every single
detail animation how to dodge with their
parry and their dexterities it's it's
wild but the great thing about this game
is even the basic player can pick this
up and be good at it I know we saw
Langston he was great yeah I want to
make sure we point out that at the
beginning of this section we saw Silver
Surfer sure what kind of impact does
Silver Surfer have at this point in the
game massive impact so about a month ago
we teased the Silver Surfer with a
four-year anniversary trailer it comes
to come and put out in response to
champions been four years since the game
is Wow
and so he flew through the history of
the battle realm leading us to this
point and when he arrives he's revealed
that there were 12 original contests our
champions in the contest and four of
them were yet to be fought so guess who
those of course Silver Surfer is
bringing back his friends the Fantastic
Four and he's found been great the first
two that's cool so it's gonna be a
year-long buildup revealing those
characters and bringing them back into
the fold of the battle oh that's awesome
of that also can you talk to us a little
bit about the alchemist and the big 7
day event yeah so there's a daily quest
that's starting today he has a matter of
fact I think I just started about an
hour ago where you're gonna play for six
days and you're gonna accrue a bunch of
elements and buffs so you're gonna do
water fire air darkness light and then
the seventh day you get to face off and
use those elements and buffs against
Diablo the ultimate Alchemist and he's
tough he's gonna be really a
a really tough challenge for you so you
definitely want to gather up as many
elements as you can take them in on that
seventh day and question Wow all right
much better this round thank you very
good good okay well great job Tim I know
you bet you've got a head off set for a
minute but you're gonna come back right
okay good good cuz we're in have more
questions for you in just a minute yeah
we're gonna see you again in a little
bit Tim and in just a second we're gonna
be joined by another member of the
mighty Marvel family Marvel Comics
editor-in-chief CD Sapolsky yeah you'll
be sitting down with us to chat all
things things so if you got a question
or a comment make sure to shoot them our
way with the hashtag fantastic for a
week we've got some great questions for
you guys so far I'm gonna pull them up
here on the Twitter just so that I can
give them to you here now comment I
always love the Human Torch he's one of
my all-time favorite superheroes we also
have any other characters lots of
question marks will blast out of Tim
when he comes back and of course yes Ben
Grimm looks great in the game looking
forward to clobbering clobbering with my
favorite character yes Fantastic Four
week love it pretty pretty good alright
but thank you for joining us in this
incredible celebration and live stream
now back together again for another
Fantastic Four announcement you know I
love it so josh is playing the thing
right now yeah as you can see right now
amazing Marvel contest of Champions what
does it like to get to see thing getting
into a game as a playable playable
character now no it's just wonderful you
know thing is one of my favorite
characters in the Marvel Universe you
know overall it's just not not just the
Fantastic Four and you know to see them
come back in comics first last year and
now to see them in the game with what
the games team has put together with
Kabam I mean it's just the way that
they've taken the comic book artwork
from all the different creators kind of
different styles and kind of made this
amazing version that just comes life
it's mind-blowing it's it's been it must
be fun for you now a year into being
editor-in-chief of Marvel Comics and
having these synergies that you're
talking about having these opportunities
we sit in the creative retreats
you know every couple months and you
have the games team and you have all the
Marvel Comics creators and those ideas
flourish it's amazing and you know
that's what's so beautiful about what
we're doing now and Marvel as a whole
it's like a good idea can come from
anywhere
just one from of our writers or you know
you know the creators on the comics but
also from members of the game team or
four people at an animation or Steve
whackers gonna phone it with something
crazy someday you know it's just it's a
complete shared synergistic environment
just completely geared for the best
stories possible for the fans I've got a
pitch for a Lord moustache we're gonna
boot that one out we're gonna save it
for 20 20 20 20 20 20 20 I'm sorry right
you guys if you enough of you tweet
nothing but there is an amazing variant
cover for a marble contest of Champions
yeah can you tell us a little bit about
how that all came into fruition you know
again it just speaks to the synergy of
what we do you know it's just the games
team working with Tom Brevoort
you know came up with the concept and I
wanna spoil it too much you know I think
there's be some more news about that
coming up soon from a from Tom is coming
up I think yes about it but you know it
just goes to the amazing creators that
we have and the different styles that
they work in and that covers just you
know so special yeah it's a good time to
be a Marvel fan whether your games are
comic fantastic for Fett for those of us
for our fans who are watching who are
maybe coming in because they're so
excited about Marvel contest of
Champions they don't know what's going
on if that has for comics you want to
tell a little bit about we don't want to
give too many spoilers but you know
after a three-year absence out in the
multiverse after Secret Wars of the
Fantastic Four are now back in the
Marvel Universe you know Reed Johnny sue
been with the kids are you know back in
New York living at for Yancy Street
water convenient address and you know
Ben and Alicia his longtime girlfriend
just went through some big changes in
their relationship and coming up Doctor
Doom and not just doctor doing but
Galactus
it's so cool and did you notice I look
for my fantastic for sure today I could
not find it
but now I do we were going to talk about
the thing so I did wear orange shoes
right don't think I did wasn't prepared
for this I did bring the marble pin too
so yeah we do have some questions from
social of course they want to know
things about the Fantastic Four and the
fam will you guys be reprinting more of
the omnibuses I love Stan and Kirby vol
3 yes there will be more coming
you know our trade paperback team Jeff
young question Grunwald catering woody
they're doing an amazing job of bringing
everything that you want the stories
that we all love and putting them into
collections and there will be a lot more
coming you know from our trade paperback
department in in the months to come over
the years we've had amazing fantastic
four stories in the pages of what if ya
and so we're reprinted I'm so excited
some that what if stuff is on my face oh
there's great fantastic four stories in
all the volumes we have more questions
anything interesting in store for the
Invisible Woman like I don't know like a
solo book or something uh stay tuned
there could be some stuff coming up for
not just sue but for some of the other
members of no chip sidarsky did it did a
great job with you know with with Johnny
and Ben before they came back and now
that they are back we will be focusing a
little bit more on some of the
individual characters so keep your eyes
loved it so much and then we just have
like a lot of big big love it's good to
see Marvel's first family back and
better than ever
not even secret work could stop them
forever oh and you know the what the
amazing mind of Dan Slott and you know
Sara Kelly kicked it off now Erin cooter
it's drawn the book there's just it just
looks better than it has in you know I
don't want to compare but he's one of my
favorite runs of all time and we're just
getting started I I read the next issue
that's coming out Venice for and I got
to a page you probably know the page I'm
talking about and I was like like I
literally felt something inside me and
so I emailed Aaron is like I would like
to buy that page from you and we'll say
it's beautiful beautiful there's it
you know all the Marvel comics are what
they are because of the heart of the
characters but you know what Dan is
injecting into the four between them and
the family dynamic and as individuals
and when it comes to the thing he's
really the heart of that team to begin
with yeah and you know now that he's in
that different place in his life and
where that relations were gonna take him
and relationship with the team and the
adventures they go on and some of the
things that you're talking about is it's
a lot of fun yeah you know one of the
things that we talk about all the time
and sometimes I forget not everybody
knows as much about Marvel as maybe some
of us folks who are here every day we
talk a lot about the history of Yancy
Street or we just kind of toss around
that word what do you mind talking a
little bit about why the Fantastic Four
moving to Yancy Street is actually kind
of a big deal you know Ben Grimm the
thing is originally from yinz Street
before he became the thing and it's a
rough-and-tumble neighborhood modeled
after the Lower East Side where you know
Stan and Jack grew up back in the day
and it's always been one of those places
have been never like going back to not
just because he had bad memories of
getting beat up because it was somewhere
that where they're still defined of the
Fantastic Four
you know the world loves and respects
him but people live on the NC Street the
people who are his age now and their
offspring still treat him with the
disregard that they have when he was a
kid so him actually buying a place and
moving back in the neighborhood where he
grew up and you know kind of defying the
face of the the the residents in that
area it really what makes the move to
Yancy Street so special and adds another
dimension to the relationship that he
has with the ancestry and with New York
City and we've been calling a thing when
he does his special move he can it's
clobberin time yeah he wraps them up in
the ground like a burrito we've been
calling it the anti street burrito
perfect right just Dan if Dennis law
wants to put a little burrito place on
yeah against the street all right we can
find some extra synergies for 2022 yeah
it's been so much fun Stevie can you
give us one more teaser for Fantastic
before this year before we let you go
all right what is one of the questions
that fans always ask about the Marvel
Universe how many teeth does Galactus
having I ask sorry can I live there
mm-hmm
good one - who is stronger the thing or
the Hulk I possibly might be answering
that question sometimes get excited oh
my goodness I
we're about to let you go but I also
want to say there were kittens
introduced into this volume with a
little bit more you and I we are big
happy will we see more of those kittens
yes the cats are here to stay and they
play an adorable role in many of the
stories coming up oh I can't think of a
better place to thank you and say I'm so
excited for everything the family will
be dear I'm like sickness has destroyed
the rain great job team up I want is it
if and when the Inhumans recover
themselves and come back to it at some
point
Lockheed done oh my goodness
we have a lot of phone calls to make
after this my ring we also want to thank
you guys the viewers there's a lot more
to come so make sure that you're using
the hashtag fantastic for week to send
us comments questions and more we've
been hearing a lot from you guys since
the livestream started so here are a
couple more that stood out to us here
all right we have I'm totally excited
for the thing and the rest of the
Fantastic Four family to join the
contest
I hope Nova was once a part of fantex
Fantastic Four I want him in there too
hehe oh good job I'd be into that yeah I
would I would love that that would be
super nice come on come on down come on
down you're the next contestant in the
Fantastic Four all right
but now back in the chair we've got Tim
Hernandez you monster he leaves you
again
Tim leads all the mobile game work we do
here at Marvel Tim thanks for coming
back of course yeah all right let's
let's see this faceoff are we gonna are
we gonna do it Josh do it no okay good
they're saying no they're saying no so
we're gonna keep on keeping on well josh
is doing a pretty awesome job there yeah
baby Tim get yeah maybe
and give him a little chance to play a
little bit yeah let's see the boss
the boy a little bit yeah let's see how
it goes and what other pro tips do you
have like what would it be a great squad
to put the thing on when you get him in
Marvel contest of Champions so one thing
I'm noticing here not to skip your
question I'll get to that but he does
not have mastery design so masteries is
I think a next-level technique that is
critical for this game so when you
progress through the story you unlock
the ability to assign masteries to your
whole team so one thing that the thing
would really use well is parry so when
you parry when you block perfectly
you're able to stun your opponent for a
couple of seconds so with the rocks that
you're trying to get those blocks in so
if you are pairing on top of that you're
stunning your opponent you're giving him
a couple of seconds to just really wall
oh sorry do it oh there it is
I he got he J got lost in the glory of
the spin I did I'm sorry yeah
so as you're talking up for the the
thing is a tank so you got you got him
on your roster yeah you're in good shape
but I think you want to get some some
some skill opponents and because you're
gonna have to counter a lot of those
bleeds and if M you're gonna want to
have like a blade
I like Archangel I mean yeah I was
referencing early Corvus glaive is nasty
in this game play Corvus glaive now so
as you can see are you doing yeah the
great thing but the thing as well is if
you can also take hits yeah some
characters you know once one or two or
three hits can take you down 50% but
take the thing can take that and I think
it's great for you know beginning
characters as well because you can you
can see how your champion does how many
there's okay it looks like we're both
back in action you know you know ice is
on you right now let's get you both back
face off Hawkeye let's see if we can get
that that run down between the two of
you who can do it quickest I want to see
that it's probably gonna be you because
you have like 500 600 attack over me
this is over you're just saying no oh
you know now you're using the one he was
using yeah I gave is that is that the
trick to it hi what's the late wreck Wow
viewers at home though viewers at home
know Italian and all comes to a Lakes it
was laying step you had the high one
last time Oh what can I say I'm just
we've got a play same person or no hey
you are you healed up and ready let me
go let me go back what so let me go to
that let me make it easy for both of us
yeah make it easy fight haka it's get on
an even keel because I know people out
there just they just want to see more
thing in action yeah because it's gonna
take a little while for people to get
their hands on the thing yeah he comes
out on Thursday so not too long that's a
lot a little bit of a wait but in the
meantime you can do the trials will be
alchemists the daily quest and then you
can start on the event quest tomorrow
all right comes down oh yeah yeah it's
kind of down three two one go series at
home you know and if they're reversed Oh
we'll find out BAM Hey alright so when
you get to fifteen rocket acts is that
right that's when you are super tough
yeah acting raw sexy you want us to use
your special if you want to even wait to
twenty then you can't even stop your
special one then you're invincible
pretty much okay
easy oh boy oh no but you just took away
a couple alright here we go
oh I I'm getting wrapped up in this
match trying to watch both friends at
the same time but we're gonna need to
get some more tips really soon Tim what
else you got for us we'd give it give us
more of those terrific tips
yes asking questions so you're gonna
you're gonna want to keep an eye out for
the other fantastic forum members
because when those get released oh we're
talking about massive synergies that's
all right I mean you got you got a good
one you got a good champion so we're not
just everyone yeah the master you you
were talking about good synergies in the
master keys so we're not just looking at
it as one character right I mentioned
earlier it's a year long event so we've
teamed Commandments planned out how
they're gonna roll out the rest of the
Fantastic Four and they're putting a lot
of thought into how they play together
as a group how you set up that roster of
that team and how they play off of each
other and really bring out the best as
the family does in the comics and in all
the stories of Fantastic Four it's about
that family bond the same thing applies
into the game that's pretty awesome
looking forward to it of the hundred and
forty characters in the game who's the
most difficult character to to acquire
is there like ultimate was Ultimates was
definitely when I first came out office
was so hard for me to get oh yeah really
difficult job on that you know I don't
have the cheat codes like Tim does no no
cheat codes allowed it's all above board
or believe me I've a ship of cheat codes
they say no but no I mean it just comes
down to how dedicated you are you could
pretty much get any character in the
game if you set your mind to it they're
they're available through arenas they're
available through standard unlocks so I
would say it's just a matter of luck
some in some ways but if you just buckle
down and you really focus and you want
to make sure that you're scoring the top
of those tournaments and those arenas
you have a good chance of getting those
care
hmm there's no one that's had children
together but you get to test the game a
lot you get to play the game a lot ahead
of time but on your personal who's the
like you said you'd like playing with
Archangel but he's is he the character
like you most like oh this is my yeah
you know for a while it was Moon Knight
just because I love Moon Knight
shout-out to Becca Macintosh Director of
Operations she loves that character
I just loved his abilities they're
actually attuned to the lunar cycle at
one time like our lunar so I guess like
the actual lunar cycle so different
abilities which yeah that was a pulling
for me but he's he's not the greatest
champion that's why I've shifted over to
he's not the great yeah no no no shade
on moon night stark Spidey and are ya
starts fighting the dune in arcades all
and yeah Corvus glaive is what's going
keeps coming up a lot yeah when as you
really went oh yeah oh it's all the way
characters gotta find someone with a
good healing ability if you take over
eating is a huge you know x-23 yeah yeah
um we have a couple questions here who
is your favorite classic Fantastic Four
villain mine is Doctor Doom it's hard to
beat Doctor Doom there's but the only
right answer is Doctor Doom home sorry
puppet master sorry everyone else behind
grind be getting married right now no
get out of here have brought him and
Alicia together maybe yeah we're getting
deep here and then we had a question
here what is your favorite Fantastic
Four comic at Bill Roseman a director of
crazed recommendation I just picked up
issue 232 okay basics mm-hmm and I
really enjoyed it I think that one right
now is up there for me
about you this I mean this man this
monster like they're the classics so
yeah the classic run is full of great
stuff actually the current run is really
good the current run is great yeah um I
actually can't remember if this in a
Hulk Runner in the same run but the
thing versus the Hulk is just such a
classic now that's pretty Joyce
yeah so many good issues now you guys
starting January 10th we're gonna need
all of you to go and download Marvel
contest of Champions and check out the
new character of the thing so you can
play yourself just head to the App Store
and Google Play Store where you can
download the game for free and remember
that you can play the January event
quest this man this monster starting
tomorrow
January 9th and the daily January quest
the trials of the elements and of course
please stay stuned here for more from
the Fantastic Four world's greatest week
livestream we're gonna take a short
break now but we will be back in just a
few minutes with some gameplay that you
will not be able to see anywhere else
but right here on marble
[Applause]
[Music]